bella tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video siamo su una nuova
serie draw my thing
io sono fa vj è qui con me per questo
primo episodio c'è un ospite speciale il
primo dual che faccio sul canale di
famiglia e tv di qualcosa fate con chi
lo fa
i box tra tutti i ragazzi eccoli gli box
del leggere gaming per chi mi conosce da
lasciare gaming e premete consiste nel
disegnare un qualcosa fanno indovinare
agli altri inizio io la mia bravura di
disegni un qualcosa di ormai risaputo
va bene ok fantastico allora ci prova
siamo qua con la tavolozza dei disegni
si esaminare ragazzi non me la ricordo
hanno aspettato un secondo che non mi
ricordo bene sì mi sono armato anche di
internet perfetto ho sbagliato tutto
allora vediamo se riuscite a capire è
difficile però in qualche modo ve lo
faccio capire con le mie doti ragazzi
guardate che bravo quell'anno per mario
ciaccia potete fare la gara
la potete fare non è difficile se se uno
ha indovinato picasso picasso questo da
questo va venduto alle mostre all'asta a
un milione questo questo è un opera che
rimarrà ne so che cosa sono disegni
disegna qualcosa sono ragazzi ok essi
come cazzo vela disegno sta cosa
[Applauso]
patata perché tutte a me devono capitare
cos'è in realtà non sono due coltelli
non mi dire niente però allora questo ce
l'ha è un fiore lower dovrebbe essere
una faccia
cos'è pinocchio
no non come cazzo me la faccio a
impossibile da disegnare dai allora
le scarpette al major germani mi fa un
baffo madonna madonna madonna famigerato
ma tutto qui tutto tutto offre a
riguardare i due fantagenitori da
piccolo ma mi sembra mi sembrava cosa
pinky con due fantagenitori fantasio
dalla stretta di mano nikic e la
bellissima no vabbè comunque raga
ne approfitto per poter partecipare
dovete mettere gli piace alla pagina di
facebook di fa vj tv è per la mente ogni
volta che iniziò un nuovo episodio lo
scrivo lì quindi i primi cinque che
partecipano entrano nel video date
semplicemente mettere mi piace alla
pagina di facebook che trovate anche
sotto in questo video
vabbè futuro cioè in futuro poi farà un
po lo facciamo anche per il gaming dove
siamo tutti e ci spacchiamo veramente
tantissimo perché siamo tutti svarianti
su queste cose che io adesso mi dovete
dire a forse sono
forse ho capito però non vediamo infatti
c'è infami il primo in classifica pure
io però mai preso no non me l'ha dato
perché l'ho scritto troppo tardi perché
non so scrivere la pagina nella batte
nessuno qui la pagina di nichi ragazzi è
in top
[Musica]
va beh non importa anche se disegnata la
cacchio state tranquilli che allora
questa è green green house ci ho provato
non solo ogni tanto esce cos'è cos'è xb
anna rea n
aveva scritto allora console ma non è
scusami console non lo so ragazza no
aspetta come si dice ho capito che call
of duty
ragazzi questo a videogame giuro che non
mi veniva videogame ti stimo t t
chiunque sia stato lo stimo
una stretta di mano virtuale perché è
stato fantastico calo farage è
fantastico
vabbè comunque un bel disegno comunque
siamo noi di hot ignorante di
proporzioni abissali si no o questo tre
lettere e car per forza cosa è per forza
io sono l'unico di idiota qui che non
capisce che diavolo può essere a una
scarpa con le rotelle
io infatti stiamo pensando a una scarpa
per o più probabilmente visto che a due
ea tre lettere la macchina io stavo
pensando una scarpa fa vj vince non ho
vinto io
e arrivato prima avente da foto di un
punto e non sa chi è stato ma uno di voi
ragazzi una battuta io sono gli otto
secondo mi ha sorpassato alla fine
perché non ho saputo rispondere macchina
va bene
sì veramente se metto il mio gatto sul
poltrona a giocare a questo gioco
disegna meglio di me ed è più
intelligente di me a capire le cose sono
troppo forti ragazzi capite c è troppo
potente ave dai facciamo un altro round
taglio finché non inizia perché sono
venti secondi sono troppi buy
ok ragazzi ci siamo di nuovo
metto questo no ma perché ho scelto no
vabbè impossibile allora io lo disegna
che non la so non è possibile non si può
disegnare una cosa del genere ma come
faccio aspettate allora facciamo un in
grigio è come non è che me lo invento io
questo mi sembra l'unico modo per
riuscire a farlo anche se troppo
difficile allora questo è da capire
ragazzi datemi una mano anche se ormai
quando state vedendo video l'ho già
disegnato se questo si può chiamare va
beh questa avete capito che cos'è
no ancora no vabbè è ok ok è qui sto
indicando con tutte le frecce possibili
no no è qui dentro
qui dentro il motore è dura vale però
tardi peccato che non abbiamo preso né
punti né io né te perché se fa
indovinare prendi qualche purista mi fa
ridere
pazienza da disegno che ragazzi ei ok ci
vuole concentrazione cioè arrivate
io mi auto e leggo capo dell'unità mai
capitano sempre persone fi madonna
madonna una donna mamma mi ha subito
mamma mia questo si capisce che cazzo di
insegnamento ci ho voluto da piccolo
genio manca monica pè ma noi due abbiamo
un'intesa che che buona
ma dai non si può ok scommetto che una
persona non va beh ci avrebbero atteso
un po grossa è un elefante
ho sbagliato a scrivere shirt io ero in
premio l'hai presa perché i tuoi ski di
sci o allora riesce ma porca si è
dimenticato il primo ratti poi la r e
poi la w alquanto restauro non si
potesse stile dice non si scrive col
trattino di mon amour
ma perché sempre tre punti cioè le ho
giocate tutte ci sono tre punti ma tutti
abbiamo più o meno tre punti chi azzecca
praticamente la prossima passa primo
questo secondo me non lo so logica la
prossima ragazzi potesse disegnando sto
ragazzo
cos'è ma cos'è dio
no veramente ragazzi c'è una pecora è
una pecora line up e non mi sembra un
alieno aveva un tumore alla zampa tra
l'altro qualcuno l'ha azzeccata
no perché qualcuno è arrivato ha preso
sette punti qualcuno qualcuno l'ha
azzeccata veramente la pec robot che mi
scrive sembra una pecora cancro cena su
steam quindi è uno che è infatti quello
che ho detto io do una pecora che ha un
tu cos'è questo cos'è questo e di
formazione efisio lui fa arabo cos'è chi
crea kick amazon idiota l'ho pensato per
d'ora ho detto non può essere quello
invece era quella anche genio che
penultimo vai e yo yo l'ultima beta 6 un
missile ragazzino cliccate tutte anno a
61 degli ultimi si sa ma parimenti agli
ultimi a pari merito va e va bene
ragazzi
direi che posso chiudere qui niente se
vi ricordate per partecipare ai temi più
a smettere mi piace alla pagina di
facebook che trovate qui sotto nella
descrizione o in ogni video che mette
comunque descrizione praticamente quando
farò un episodio di drome thing lo
scriverò ragazzi i primi cinque che
partecipano apriranno il prossimo video
l'ho già detto se sono stati scritti
iscrivetevi a voci dal prossimo video
bei ragazzi